good morning everyone my name is jack
balkin I'm the director of Yale's
information society project and I have
this very simple and easy job this is
really all i do i I show up at the
beginning of a conference and I
basically tell you all hello it's so
nice to have you here and then I tell
you a little bit about the information
society project and why we came up with
this conference and then I sit down and
basically that's all my job consists in
I'm basically just a front man for for
these wonderful people at the
information society project who do so
much work every year I had to put on
these wonderful conferences this is by
the way our 12th year and we we existed
long before the kindle and many other
things but anyway and we've been
watching these things happen and
studying them how did we decide that we
were going to do a conference on
libraries 2 point 0 and the answer is
very simple we have been working on
problems of how to secure access to
knowledge in a digital age and produce
knowledge for development we have been
working on issues of civil liberties
online we have been working on issues of
digital education and how to make
educational materials available to more
people around the world we have been
working on issues of privacy and and
many other questions and every time we
studied one of these questions whether
it was digital education or access to
knowledge of privacy or civil liberties
online we were always brought back to
the group of issues involving libraries
and archives and so we thought well
since we keep getting led back to these
issues we might as well just have a
conference on libraries 2 point 0 so we
approached the room Housing Committee at
Yale which is which funds various
enterprises and we told them about this
project and at first they didn't quite
get it but but they didn't understand
what you understand you're all here
because you understand the importance of
it but eventually they did and they got
behind it and
and we're very grateful to them for
funding this conference and making it
possible for all of you to be here and
we have a lot of stuff a lot of
interesting things packed into one day
and so I am I will begin the festivities
by introducing my very good friend the
executive director of Yale's information
society project Lord and artists thank
you good morning everyone and welcome to
the library to point o symposium on
behalf of the Yale information society
project and Yale Law School what I would
like to do is try something a little bit
different this morning if I could ask
Perry to come up here so this symposium
is really about digital information
centers it's about the digital
dissemination of information and it's
about the digital interaction
surrounding this information so what I
have decided to do is to give my remarks
digitally so I have made a movie montage
I spent a little time in the last week
with my laptop and with my camera so I
hope you enjoy it please watch the video
you
these racks and shelves contain a lot of
books tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands perhaps millions how do you
feel about because when you have these
two important qualifications love for
books and love for people you may well
consider the vocation of a librarian
well the civilized world except as
unforgivable sin talking out loud with
any librarian
I'm pretty sure that was library one
point out we don't have cookies no
cookies just books that's all no cookies
understand just books books we're really
on library four-point-oh the only reason
we talked about library 24 million is to
match it up we have to point out but
during my career as a librarian we've
gone through at least four stages in
libraries the library 1 point 0 was a
print-based library and this was a
library that was dominating full of
fight the print resources books journals
and the access to those print resources
will print card catalogs and indexes
don't you know the three decimal system
library 2.0 s when we move from the
access to those print information
resources to an online access so we have
large integrated library systems and
we're not develop in-house by libraries
library 3.0 is when we added web
concepts more recently with web two
point on concepts that is social
networking we entered what we call now
why where people know but it's really
library for one
you
you
we try to reach out to our patrons in a
variety of ways electronically so we
have access through nebo googletalk your
aim students can email us whenever it
have a question i oftentimes found
myself meeting a student after having 15
conversations with them online
this right
we have a completely 2 point 0
environment here at Yale Law School
we're using variety of ways we have our
catalog open to our patrons to tag
bibliographic records so they and other
researchers and find them but based on
the terms of define most useful we're
using delicious to offer bookmark civil
useful websites to our patrons we have a
presence on Facebook it allows people to
search our catalog and search WorldCat
and some other materials and communicate
with us and we also have quite a large
number of us are on Twitter and the
library itself is Twitter so we're
communicating with our patrons back and
forth through Twitter as well
did you have to leave
ready
baby
Oh
oh look I I may not be an explorer Oh or
an adventurer or a treasure seeker or
gunfighter mr. O'Connell but I am proud
of what I am and what is that I am I
librarian good morning everyone my name
is Laura Dean artists on behalf of the
Yale information society project we're
so happy you could join us today welcome
to the library to point o symposium
you
you might even see I had a lot of fun
over the last week and thanks very much
to my brains that work that they put
that together so we're having fun and in
addition to reflecting one person's
vision of life great I know this video
actually does foreshadow a lot of issues
that will arise in this conference which
clip do you think raises the most
prominent issues for for example the
ethics and politics of library to point
o panel clearly it's the Sesame Street
clip they were debating and they had a
very important dialogue about books
versus cookies and I'm sure that it was
not lost on this crowd that they were
talking about tracking cookies and the
date of attention and privacy issues
associated with that certainly the
entire video raises questions about
copyright so if I this is will call this
a pseudo academic presentation but if I
wanted to show this to my class on
Wednesday and I wanted to have it
archived in some kind of a publicly
accessible OpenCourseWare environment
that perhaps a library would maintain
would I be able to post this online and
what is the role of the librarian in
determining and actually looking at
these types of materials in determining
whether it's okay to put it up from an
intellectual property standpoint so it
does raise a few issues but really it
was just too to be fun you might have
noticed the song did anyone know what
song that was playing at the end it was
a song by greenday the band and it's
actually called in the library so you
might have noticed that the word library
was not mentioned at all in in the song
so you don't have to be in a library to
be in a library I think that's what that
says about the song but similar to that
you don't have to be at this event to be
at this event I'm very happy that
everyone is here but I would like to say
a few things about how we're going to
digitally distribute this symposium in
both space and time so let me fill you
in on a few things you'll notice perhaps
that we're filming today we have the
crew up in the balcony and we will be
making these videos available on YouTube
through Yale's youtube channel so that
will be available to a wider audience in
an international audience so we're doing
that
we also have a Facebook 2 point 0
interest group if anyone is interested
in joining that we are also audio
recording so we will make those podcasts
available on the Yale ISP website which
is is P dot law ledu so we'll do that I
know a lot of people are blogging today
in addition to our individual blogs we
thought we would try a crowdsourcing
blog environment so we have a blog setup
it's if anyone wants to write this down
it is yale isp blog dot net that's yale
isp blog net so we have people assigned
to take some notes on the speakers to
post that pretty quickly on to the
website and then we could all comment so
we will be respectful towards the
speakers but we'll just comment on the
topics and maybe we could create
something really interesting out of this
conference if we all put our ideas out
there so we there's a flickr account
that's link to the blog if anyone would
like to take some cell phone pictures or
if they have their camera you're welcome
to post those photos onto our flickr
account link to the blog so let me give
you that information as well you can log
onto flickr under the name information
society project so that's easy to
remember and the password what do you
think the password is library two point
oh ok so everyone's okay with that we're
also going to be twittering today so if
anyone is into twittering please feel
free to send your tweets to hash live 20
so it's pound Li be 20 if you haven't
noticed this already this auditorium was
built before any of these technologies
were available so the signal can
sometimes be week when we have a big
group of people the signal is strongest
in the back so it won't hurt our
feelings if people are crowded in the
back as we progress throughout the day
we also don't have electrical capability
to accommodate all of these people so
there are plenty of outlets in the
registration room room 122 and in the
dining hall so we can all charged up
later hopefully you had a chance to pick
up the schedule there's more information
available on our website which I
mentioned before is pol edu we have the
speakers BIOS we have information
the information society project and the
program committee and other useful
information there we tried to minimize
the amount of paper that we used so
those are some of the electronic things
I also wanted to mention that we're
going to have an extemporaneous exercise
in so in an intellectual exchange of
ideas here it's very informal we'd like
to encourage the formation of birds of a
feather groups during lunch so for
example is Stephen Schultz here yet he
is going to organize a birds of a
feather group on pacer we also will have
one Emma Alonso who's up here in the
front she's going to organize one on the
google book settlement and i know that
we're going to have others as well so
think about during the first panel
whether you would like to organize a
birds of a feather group and then
approached me during the break and tell
me what it will be on and then I'll
announce it before the second panel so
we will do that and it will really be
wonderful to see how the day proceeds
both digitally and in person with these
informal interactions finally I would
like to say a special thanks and
acknowledge that the symposium is made
possible by the generosity of the Oscar
em Roop housing fund at yale law school
so we truly appreciate this generosity